i've got some great video to show you i  don't know if you've ever seen  this is called a dolphin stampede off  the coast of california this was newport  beach over the weekend  and this was around a whale expedition  sightseeing boat and hundreds they say  maybe up to 2 000 dolphins  just started stampeding along by the  boat  and it's it's not anything where they're  angry and biologists don't really know  why they do it  but they just swim so so fast  and they're they're either chasing a  food source or maybe they're being  chased by a predator  they don't know but it is an amazing  sight very exciting  if you're ever able to see one so really  cool dolphin stampede